greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday the 19th of June the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by manscape let me tell you something
what Joe is here to tell you one thing
and one thing only don't cut your dick
off [ __ ] oh the suffering and the
anxiety ends now today with manscape you
get it done without the pain you're like
Joey what the [ __ ] is manscape manscape
they have precision tools for the family
jewels if you know what I mean manscaped
has redesigned the electric razor ok
their invention is called the lawn mower
a handheld razor with skin-safe
technologies so [ __ ] tremendous it
won't Nick or snag your nutsack or your
[ __ ] love Pole you can't get that
from nobody else you want to go easy on
what the Lord gave you have your wife
trying to [ __ ] trim your nut is the
anxiety and the green you close your
eyes you're like [ __ ] it it's a 50/50
[ __ ] shot I'm gonna sing like a
[ __ ] bird after this you don't know
what's gonna happen but I can talk here
to the [ __ ] tongue to my tongue is
green all I got to tell you is one thing
manscape works they also have a crop
reserved especially formulated deodorant
so your balls don't stink like dick and
the revival a sprint that tones and
refreshes your nutsack and the area
around your [ __ ] stick dick so it
smells cool it's refreshed we're going
into the summer season now understand me
you want to have that area [ __ ]
tip-top Magoo because you never know
what's gonna happen
listeners of the church the church
family can get 20% off your first order
when you use promo code Church CH you
are CH at manscape calm and if you order
the perfect package so also on a free
travel bag when you use promo code
Church that's manscape com
use promo code Church to get not 10 but
20% off your first dollar
just remember it's summertime you want
to keep your balls clean also the church
is also brought to you by one of my
favorite [ __ ] products in the world
CBD lion calm listen to me everywhere
you drive now you see a sign we got CBD
we got this we got that you don't know
what the [ __ ] you
mine with CBD line you know what to [ __ ]
you again
why I tell you why one number one they
make CBD products from start to finish
CBD line has you covered whether it's
the vape the cartridges to shatter taint
your gummies CBD line is the way to go
number two I'll tell you I'd go with CBD
line because you could check that third
party laughter results yourself on their
website when you go to CBD Lyon dot-com
that's why so do me a favor if you're
looking for you need haven't been I
don't know where to get it I don't know
which brand to get listen uncle Joey
[ __ ] knows I'm 56
I grow sidekicks for Jesus and I gonna
strength [ __ ] training and I'll tell
you what's keeping me together
CBD lion calm so go to CBD line calm and
prescient church on the way out CH you
are CH and get 20% off your first
daughter alright who's better than you
kick this [ __ ] mealy what can I
say
how are you alright greatly great to see
you look beautiful
thank you it's great to be here and life
has been very kind to you you've been
very kind to life yeah yeah work so
though you know before we even start
talking my introduction to you was the
same way I was introduced to Richard
Pryor as a child so as you were getting
closer to come on the emotions started
to come up you're a big part of my
childhood
uh-huh great you know when I was growin
I was 15 this the word on the street was
if you don't have Led Zeppelin to make
your house like if I walked into your
house you invited me in like you want to
be you want to get high and let's go
pick a record I go do your thing and I
don't see Led Zeppelin - I walk out with
one point in life where we walked into
your house and you didn't have big
bamboo we couldn't we couldn't hang out
with you
we couldn't hang out with you like
where's big bamboo my mother didn't give
me the money yet listen call me when
your mom give you the money
[ __ ] you a [ __ ] if you didn't have that
big [ __ ] thing you know I started
smoking pot maybe 1975 I kept it in the
closet yeah
it was like a gay guy on yeah you know
it was like a gay guy on Beverly
Boulevard I wasn't ready for Santa
Monica yet and I was like I wasn't
letting nobody know I got high and the
first time I listened to them guy I'm
CUBAN Bolger Catholic raised and then
but let's back it up a little bit before
I even got high I had a sister Ella I
went to Catholic boarding school and the
nuns used to beat us and one day some
kid brought in a [ __ ] album and we
put it on during class and sister Mary
sister Mary Ellen
so our goal in those days was to go in
and torture the nuns the same way those
kids sister Mary elephant so that was
the first beginning of it you know who
are these guys Cheech and Chong ba ba ba
you know some kin had the album from the
Bronx and then big bamboo and I had big
bamboo and los Cochinos sure and one of
my all-time for because my mother had a
bar so my mother they talked about drugs
and Takata in the house and you know
reefers [ __ ] the [ __ ] how to make a
drug deal or let's say you're doing I
will never forget that these are you
know it's like I don't forget Richard
Pryor [ __ ] meets wine oh yeah [ __ ]
meet
wino meets Dracula you know those bits
they'll be in my mind forever sister
Mary elephant will be in my mind forever
yeah and let's make a dope deal
because it was like a a spoof on let's
make a deal yeah [ __ ] you know so I
just want to start with that I still
remember going to Jersey City on the
Saturday and doing microdot acid mm-hmm
and seeing up and smoke with 29 kids in
the movie neither losing your mind when
they made that when they made the truck
out of marijuana gin the muffler started
burning it and all the security guys
were [ __ ] high you know this was just
that was our life yeah it was coming to
see you watch you and then I'm sure you
were one of the motivate it's nuts
smoking dope I'm not gonna blame it on
you like
briefs made me kill myself go [ __ ]
yourself all right Judas Priest didn't
hang you kid you dumb [ __ ] you did well
we used to say you know when when they
came down on us you know we'd we'd be on
radio stations you know they would be
you know how do you feel you know
turning all these kids on the drugs and
that and so my thing was in fact I said
what if we're right what if what we were
doing back then was the right thing to
do
and it turned out to be the right thing
and so now that is legal man it's like
you know Cheech and I both walk around
me you know yeah we did it then you know
it's it's legal and it should be because
it's healthy yeah it's just another day
in paradise we don't especially if
you've done the spectrum of drugs like I
I was an [ __ ] growing up I was a
criminal so I did the spectrum of drugs
what kind of crime I was a [ __ ] petty
thief really a coke dealer you know I
did whatever my mom died my I lost faith
in the system I was faith in myself and
I just did anything I could do it uh it
was this in Jersey in Jersey New York
City area yeah well that's what you do
and you know you break down and you just
do [ __ ] in one bag on trouble and then I
learned my lesson [ __ ] no you know I
came up I kept [ __ ] around
well you found out how to get into the
best prisons yeah well you find that
it's funny the guy that got me into the
best prison died two weeks ago I got the
email last week I went to him before I
got locked up this him and I had similar
crimes so I went to him and he goes I'll
make calls for you so when I got the
diagnostic I already had an in oh yeah
and that's very important as soon as I
got the diagnostic patient asked for
this certain guy tell him it came by
Accenture God rest his soul and you know
I had the best slippers well yeah it
seemed as me well yeah when they were
gonna put me in the word went out you
know and I'm such a celebrity with
everybody in the system oh my god and so
when I got there with
it was a royal wedding
yeah everybody lined up outside the
prison are you doing mr. Charlie and
they said for tradition or whatever it
is legally they have to handcuff me to
walk-in into the door and then once I'm
in the door they take off the handcuffs
it's just symbolic because actually they
let me you know self booty-call
surrender self surrender yeah and so
Vanity Fair sent a sent me a writer and
a limo to take me from my house to
prison
that's who you're owed to prison in the
limousine got stopped by the cops for
speeding and the driver said we got
Tommy Chong going to prison the guy says
okay go ahead
you know ain't no ticket just to get him
into jail and when I got there when I
when they processed me and they had me
there was two prisons there was the main
the main joint in the in the front of
the Princeton and I was in the camp at
the back and so when you go through the
front door you know it's a real lock
down the the official language in that
prison was Spanish so so it was a tough
tough prison behind there was the camp
and was up full of celebrities and
lawyers and doctors and white collar
people and so the guy that had to drive
me there as soon as I got in the truck
in the pickup truck he pulls out a
Cheech and Chong Li album he says will
you sign this for me and so but and then
when I got in the joint I was greeted
and the first guy was great news a
little Spanish guy named Tony and he
goes hey come on I got some hand-picked
Dickies you know the the uniform you
have to wear he had some but he got
antique Dickies that they were saving
you know that it's a clothes guy and so
I'm sorry I got I got these I had a
beautiful uniform it was crazy man
and all I did
I was there besides go to school I went
to school I had free rein basically in
the the only thing how I really started
doing the minute I walked in was let's
take pictures with the inmates and then
the visiting thing filled up because
they heard I was there and so it was
like a meet and greet every Sunday and
then they they said okay no more
pictures you know that was a big deal
from there but it was it was it was fun
then we shot our video and I they let me
use the warden's office and you know you
know how it is when you're where you're
shooting your movie you can tell
everybody to shut up everybody shut up
and so we didn't have we're just sitting
around bullshitting and I said because I
could hear the warden everybody walking
and talking and that so I just leaned my
head up the door goes hey quiet in here
we're shooting they oh okay it's like I
had the word tiptoeing around what
prison did you you know you you were
gonna charge with a federal yeah it was
okay so you ended up going to Lompoc and
no I went to Taft and where's tap Taft
is outside of Bakersfield okay just
outside of Bakersfield it was originally
a woman's prison and so we had showers
with doors on them we had the shooters
with doors on you know it was a woman's
prison suddenly how many people in the
prison in in our camp there was I think
404 I saw 200 200 and there's two
dormitories a and B and and they had a
gay dormitory a gay old man dormitory
that's when I was in and then be you
know the other prisoners but you had to
be nonviolent and right there was a lot
of things that's it was a camp it was a
camp but we had running tracks we had
you couldn't weightlifter anymore they
stopped the weights and so everybody was
like chin-ups and you know dips and but
they had a running track and a football
field basketball court and I was I was
taking tango at the time a tango dancing
so are you
to go to the basketball court and
practice my tango walk and and because
I'm a entertainer you know I'm used to
people looking at me so I wasn't worried
about that it's so I had a but continued
bikers there's a lot of the peaceful
bikers of Mongols and Pau
Hells Angels in a lot of those guys but
they they were hardened criminals but
they were peaceful so they were in the
camp and they would gather around to
watch me why do my tango walk and then
one day Steve big old banker goes hey
John you don't have to dance alone here
I'll dance with you rrroar
so I walked over to him because in tango
dancing with men is quite common so I
took him in my arms and he became my
best friend and my dog and so when we
were and and now he was like my teach
man I had i tortured this you that it is
like we played pool and I beat him and
then I wouldn't play him again because
I'm mad and he was a pool shark and so
and he might have let me beat him the
first game but I would never played him
again the whole day the whole time I was
there you had a good time with in it oh
man I had a good sign I had the best
time at a good time I had to bet it's
great how long it's time to jet did they
make you do nine months nine months a
month yeah and it goes fast it went how
was the food in your situation well we
had our own private chef the good
fellows yeah exactly we had a his name
is Eric Larson he's a pro golf caddie he
was a golf caddie for Mark Calcavecchia
and he was in on a very bum rap you know
like he would buy cocaine from this girl
and so the feds busted the girl and they
said we need a name and and so the she
give him Eric's you know he was closer
to a name that she had and so the feds
went after Eric and they offered him
five years in Eric's
Nonis because he was in a dealer he was
a caddy and so he fought it and he
one and then they reap robbed the
charges and he couldn't afford the the
second one you can't beat the feds and
so he thing him of I think 15 years and
he did twelve eleven when I was there
you know what the most shot I mean I'm
sure I'm not saying that you were scared
before you were then but you had some
doubts you had never been in jail before
all this I think the biggest shock to
you and me was the stories you hear in
there yeah about how the government
works oh if you tell people like I would
love to sit with somebody fit I have ten
hours yeah of undercover stories that
yeah people would die they go Joey
you're lying and I mean they can't
believe it
you you cannot believe how the federal
government works there's a guy in there
that was you might still be in there but
he was supposed to be released a year
before I went in and because of the
paperwork they won't they won't release
him and he's got no way to you know but
on the other hand it's a federal prison
and so they have to give you the medical
and so there's I met guys in there that
had never they weren't criminals but
they had a have the open heart surgery
or they would die and so they would
commit a crime to end up in the federal
system and get to get the operation so
it's a whole crazy except [ __ ] you
would not people on the streets with not
normal people would go Joey
I love you but you're lying lift that
would never happen stories of when cuz
Mike I was arrested for kidnapping so
they put me in County first kidnapping
yes
but it becomes federal kidnapping one
and two and aggravation she wouldn't go
up with you that's thick so what
happened was when you get arrested for
federal when you go in and you're there
I think it's takes 72 hours for them to
decide whether they gonna charge you on
the state the feds couldn't make a
decision up because I had been in
trouble in Aspen I was in on some Aspen
type drug stuff and the D
I got involved so until they wanted to
talk to me briefed me or whatever to try
to make me a deal the DEA the feds held
on to me I was like a ploy and I kept
saying why am I still here after 72 day
hours and they're like wow they're still
deciding you guys have to decide by now
they don't
the feds are a different game and then
when people heard me on the phone they
would come over and go listen man that
ain't nothing it would start hearing
[ __ ] about you know this one guy was in
there now when you go to prison you know
who's lying to you
you know who's telling you the truth
yeah if I'm telling you I'm a kingpin
along with someone bumming a cigarette
for me yeah there's a [ __ ] problem
okay no the problem is if you leave them
if you leave rightly believe but there's
guys in there that every visitation they
got a different broad visiting them yeah
bringing them food giving them ten that
I mean it's [ __ ] crazy yeah and this
guy was telling your story how you know
this fed was his friend at two years and
he goes everything I did the guy did and
he goes we got so strung out on blow
then we started shooting it he goes he
was a Fed shooting it with me not for
shot a shot and he goes I couldn't
figure it out when they arrested me they
made me try to make me do a deal real
fast and he goes I turned her down my
attorney Mona take of a trial they kept
pushing her back because the guy had
become a junkie and he got off the coke
and they couldn't figure out how are
they were gonna testify against them
they had a little bit of tape the
stories are endless endless endless like
they have a little bit of tape so they
couldn't really process so this guy
waited two years to go on trial like
just because they had a cleaner and he
goes the guy came in looking like
[ __ ] Johnny Pavarotti two years later
and he denied everything there's no more
coke in his blood it's your word against
mine and he's a friend and he's not you
know when you hear about the athletes
you did a very popular show that I
[ __ ] because you did all the movies
then my mother died in 79 and I went off
the deep end and I lost track of chichén
[ __ ] charm
I was living up my own cheats in China
it's bringing in vans and guns and [ __ ]
one day I'm watching TV I'm watching my
favorite TV show on Friday night and who
[ __ ] pops up but Chung has it it's a
great episode about pirates oh you miss
cocaine it was one of Miami vices in
Miami buddies it was one of the dealer
dealer but you said a line in there that
I still use today but one of the best my
first show your name was either jumbo
your name was jumbo jumbo you had a
chubby wife whether she lived in the
trailer and this they come to you first
you cut the deal and then when they come
to you the second time it's nighttime
and it's young kids they have trust fund
kids yeah and they pull up and they
leave the lights on and you pull out
like with a [ __ ] gun and you look at
the manure
turn off the lights this ain't a goddamn
spy movie so this day I still use that
[ __ ] line turn off the lights dog
this ain't no [ __ ] smart yeah that
was my one Miami boy Miami Vice and
stuff that was fun that was a great
episode yeah yeah it was good but we
were getting back to the feds and all
that [ __ ]
I never stories in there yeah that how
they the feds broke up a family I was in
there with a family called the Marquis a
Longmont Colorado and they [ __ ] were
what do you know they mow your lawn oh
yeah there's gardeners there's nothing
being the landscape artist and long have
you been to Longmont Colorado it's
outside of Boulder I've been to Boulder
it's outside a ball to reach I'll back
that it was a mom-and-pop community yeah
you drove true you could smell cow [ __ ]
now it's a metropolis yeah because it's
next to Boulder yeah but at that time
was it wasn't the the the best place in
the [ __ ] world I forgot what I was
gonna tell you that Oh
so the Markley started the young kid
bought a gram of coke one day and it
went on and so forth and they were
making millions a month
someone coke from A to Z in Longmont
they were getting it from some Mexicans
and what they were doing was they were
selling 1/2 grams and grams kilos they
were out of their minds there were
Yahoo's this it's 1986 nobody really
know about cocaine and it's a
mom-and-pop situation so it was him and
his father didn't even know how to wash
the money so they started buying
tractors and [ __ ] lawn mowers they
had 200 lawn mowers
it was the only [ __ ] gardening
company I was making 2 million on the
books if they had no idea it was him and
his father cutting trees they're making
two million dollars now I don't even
know how to watch the money that's how
they got caught
yeah the feds stayed at their house when
they arrested them the feds stayed at
their house for 24 hours and said when
they were Congo Chun I'm coming over to
pick up an Eightball they would go no
this ain't Chung this is Phil his nephew
come on over
they sold coke for 24 hours without
arresting any of the people just 2
o'clock the type of business they were
doing yeah
so they posed as dealers for 24 hours
everybody who bought coke from them that
ain't nothing then they got arrested
other Fattah they [ __ ] got arrested
and they brought him into jail so it was
the father the son and the wife and then
they took the son and they made up a
whole story they had pictures of you
know like me and Cheung talking me and
you smoking a joint they put a picture
of Chung and the guy's wife together and
told him that his father was having an
affair when it's [ __ ] all right the
feds are cold-blooded that's why the
tapes that's why whenever they tape you
you always hire audible experts you
spend extra ten thousand and you hire an
ex-fbi got because the ex-fbi guy will
go yeah they just mix those in together
yeah so it's it's you and Tim haven't
it's Tony and Chun having a conversation
about eating cake and all of a sudden
you hear my voice going to Cheung make
the delivery yeah yeah give me 12 cakes
you know and then though they go to
court and they go cake
was kilos and chunks in there what are
you talking about [ __ ] you've never
heard these things but what about what
they did with me they law we had a bomb
company glass company and so Ashcroft
and Bush and them they were starting the
Iraqi war so they needed a diversion you
know and so they put out the press thing
that paraphernalia is funding the
terrorists all the money we're making
the billions were making up bomb cells
is going into to help the terrorists and
so they put an undercover guy him in in
our bond company and all he did was
straighten our bond company out so who's
running properly because we were losing
money like crazy maze and so then when
they busted us they knew that we were
losing money but they had gone on with
this thing and so they needed the name
they needed the the Cheech and Chong
name and so they they busted us and then
they they just give me a deal they said
either you give up or we'll go after
your son right I know you stuck up yes I
am and and your wife because she wrote
the check and me yeah and it wasn't a
nothing illegal was going on but the and
then they had us they taped us there
they taped them trying to buy bonds from
us and our company wouldn't send it to
him they said no sorry we were not
allowed to ship the bongs to to
Pennsylvania and so the feds came in
person to the to the thing and they
already had an undercover guy in our
business anyway and so they arranged to
send a shipment to Pennsylvania which
you gave them the evidence to bust me
and it was all illegal it was entrapment
you know it was Undercovers everything
the feds did everything you know illegal
but when they said either you go or your
son goes you know and then I said I'll
go for sure you know because I wanted
the adventure anyway Wow were you scared
when you walked in no not a bit how old
really when you walk I grew up
Calgary Alberta Canada I was in my 60s
late 60s I grew up in Canada in
Vancouver WA Calgary and kept in
Vancouver and the only people I really
knew because I had a nightclub to so I
were gangsters you know that was the
only people I really knew so I knew I
knew that life better than I knew you
know the college life and so before
music you had a club in Vancouver yeah
and then you I was in a band
music that was a [ __ ] Motown but yes
yes is that true oh yeah yes ago and I'm
we had one of the best R&B singers in
the world he's dead now but Bobby Taylor
was a legend and what was naming you bad
Bobby chillin the bankers and the reason
it was called Bobby Taylor in the
Vancouver's was that we never had a name
we're a bar band and spent some when
they said what's the name of the group
and so with Bobby and I he got me into
comedy he was like I'm a funny funny guy
very funny
I called black guys you know the the in
the jazz R&B world they all they're all
comedians but the thing is they can sing
you know but they can they can be
trouble and so well when they asked does
the name of our band we never had a name
and so we're thinking of crazy names and
there was a band in Texas at the time no
no this was I had to be 1966-67 yeah
around 66 when we got a discovered 1966
there was a band in Texas called ten
screaming [ __ ] and so he said why
don't we call our band for [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] okay so we put it up on the
marquee for [ __ ] and now appearing
for New Year's in a chain and that night
we had we had one audience what customer
it was a very angry black lady wrestler
named Lottie the body and Lottie sat in
the front row we played a set we played
a song and two and she is well I see the
[ __ ] but where's the [ __ ] know my
dad was Chinese he didn't know about the
sign he's a doorman and so he walked
over to her to tell her you know you
don't talk like that
and she picked him up at body-slamming
Lord so I took my guitar down I ran down
there she picked me up body slam my ass
and all the brothers on the stage were
laughing their ass off man they were
just cracking up and so we changed the
name to four color guys in the Chinese
land and Motown said no no no no not
what year is this 1966 67 66 I'm just
getting off the boat from Cuba playing
where they got me yeah yeah we we did
our record in 1967 and we changed Motown
because it was the first interracial
song you know does your mama know about
me and so Diana Ross was she was the one
that really discovered us she came to
the club with the rest of the Supremes
they saw us play and she fell in love
with the she actually found them with a
drummer because she stole the drummer
soon as we went to Motown she stole her
drummer but that was okay because we had
a lot of drummers but yeah we were the
first in a lot of ways and then we
discovered the Jackson 5 they opened for
us when they were then when a high
school contest and and so barbecue later
in the vancouver's and jury Butler were
playing at the Regal theater in Chicago
and Jackson 5 opened the show and they
were the Jackson 5 plus Johnny because
the little cousin there and so a Bobby
Taylor told Michael and Joel his father
to make him come on to Detroit we'll get
you signed with Motown and so they came
and stayed at Bobby's house for about a
month but took a month before they
finally auditioned them and then the
rest is history
did you ever been any other Jacksons
always oh yeah we're still pretty we're
tight we have that history you know
because Jermaine Jermaine was really the
the one that bonded with me the most he
actually did a cover does your mama know
about me and I saw Michael Cheech never
really believed that story you know and
so when we saw Michael at
and a Grammy the 25-year Grammy get
together Bob
teach went over to Michael and asked him
if that story was true and Michael said
yeah yeah he discovered us yeah there
was Bob dinner and then Michael asked me
when he tried to talk a little comedy
with me
he said Tommy do you think Bobby's funny
no I took it to mean did I think bobby
was gay and just bobby was notorious see
he's got a reputation having a big ron
jeremy you know and so and I thought is
he gay
yeah probably yes so I said yeah he's
probably is funny and but he was trying
to talk comedy you know Michael like he
likes to be an expert of everything but
yeah it was fun that whole year was
crowded that band and how did that band
did you guys break up oh yeah
immediately as soon as you get a hit
well you know soon as they they they
could pull Bobby away from the rest of
the band they just want the singer they
don't want to ban and so so that's what
they did the producers you know and then
I got fired I got fired from Motown but
because Barry knew my contribution to
everything because I meant but we met
Barry right right in the beginning when
were over to his house and and we had
Tom beard the guy that wrote the music
genius Ebro does your mama know about me
the music he he we had to fly him in
because we just showed up with the band
and Barrett wanted the songwriters sure
that's what he was looking for it so we
we got Tom Baird in there and Tom Baird
he's got the singer perfect pitch he
could hear anything absorb al or
something to tell you what note it is
and he he mesmerized Barry Gordy with it
Barry Gordy would when he heard the
doorbell and Tom named off the the notes
Barry went over to the piano and checked
it out oh it's right it's right so he he
really and and Barry would always talked
to me even though we never had a leader
of the band
I was you know the the unofficial leader
and so Barry always talked to me so when
I got fired because after the band broke
up Bobby went on his own we had a backup
a singer named Chris Clark which was a
cool gig but I had to get a green card
because we're Canadians we know we got
self deported from from Motown and into
Windsor and so I I had to miss a gig to
go get my green card you know because
you don't mess around with the green
card and so the the tour manager at the
time singer named Johnny Bristol he told
me he says if you leave you're fired you
know I didn't even argue with him I just
sittin okay so I had to get I got my
green card to come back and I was fired
and and my girlfriend at the time Shelby
she was in the motel that was the reason
I had to go they never gave me a ticket
back from from Detroit to Cherry Hill in
New Jersey where it was I had to go back
get my guitar my instruments my
girlfriend and the baby so you go back
what shall be that well yeah yeah oh my
god and she was she was the one that
said I walked in she's all you're
finished early and I said no I got fired
she says that that's good honey come to
bed that band sucked that was my lady
that said that and so oh yeah she was
the one that that got me then I then we
got a nice settlement from Barry Gordy
you know because Barry phoned me up
right away and he said man you're not
fired to come on
and I said I think I'm gonna stay fired
I want to become a Barry Gordy I don't
want to just work for one and Barry says
I I respect that so he gave me $5,000
and little severance and we went to
California and then from the California
had to go back to the nightclubs because
I had no band now the nightclub you had
any bank over ya would have become a
strip club or no I had to either both
were given to me
the first club was an after-hours Club
the guy that owned the building he knew
man he said to made you want to club and
I said yeah
there was an empty steakhouse so we
opened a after-hours Club there and we
went for like five years and credibly
packed every night because we had the
good music and then because we've done
that with that Club this other failing
the booty called a dinner club you know
a friend of mine it was in Chinatown bad
location but he said do one another club
and I said yeah sure
so we opened the we changed it from
dinner club into a strip joint
Vancouver's first strip joint and we
have pictures we got a documentary
coming on them and it'll show all that
that year on what year was a strip club
and that was in 60s it was 60 probably
65 66 67 yeah and there and what is
Cheech coming to all this well I started
the strip club after I came back from
being fired from Motel now ah one
question Slocum populists oh yeah you're
already smoking bar yeah what was the
popular strains at 66 like come on being
gold
it was Klan amar red it was called some
you got some yeah I got something that's
it I need some didn't matter
we both say hashing in Vancouver right
right because we got hash from Vietnam
actually we got a lot of weed coming
from it was during the war and so we had
a lot of we come in and then the David
smuggler from India and you know the
hash mostly hash because if she's an
father yeah yeah but her word hash balls
he would make cash balls stick it in the
in the speaker cabinets of bass guitars
that's one way of doing it we smoked a
lot of hash mostly but when we when we
got the strip club when I came back to
work the strip club it was a it was
going good you know the girls were
dancing and we had a singer and a band
playing and that but it was boring and
I'd seen second city and I'd seen the
midian Vancouver I mean in Los Angeles
and so I had an idea of turning the
girls into actresses instead of having
them because the when they would come to
work they were beautiful young got fresh
you know beautiful and then would put on
that strip costume you everything about
the they started looking a little [ __ ]
you know and so I thought wow it'd be
great if I got them onstage as they are
and then strip you know and and then do
it in in the context of a play or of a
bit you know and so we changed the strip
thing into into a improvisational acting
thing and then we had a straight man
first of all we had a tap dancer that
was taps Harrah's you know black guy who
was tap dancing he would use the emcee
for the strippers and so when I changed
the show and into a play the play the
first play was it was a pajama party and
so the girls would act the stage was
survive it was her bedroom and and so
they would come over and greet each
other hey yeah how are you doing and
like the after the gig and so they would
get out of there
there their street clothes and put on
the little baby job pajamas and you know
it was a strip joint a strip show
and then taps comes over to visit him
and and they said taps man why don't
they call you taps and he's a top dancer
well show us what you get that you got
you got so we had a band so they play a
tap music and tap danced he was so good
that he got an encore
and he was pretty old encore almost
killed him if it's so he quit that night
he says I can't do this man I'm right
here and so I had a doorman that was
very funny guy named Dave Dave Graham
and I said to Dave Dave I need a emcee
you know I need a guy on stage and he's
I'll do it if you do it sorry okay and
so next thing I know Dave and I wear two
long-haired hippies on stage doing doing
comedy and then
we had a straight man higher than a suit
as soon as we turned it into an acting
thing all the actors converged on the
club and so we had a straight man of
actor named Rick Linz and only trouble
is that we got so popular the the
newspaper had a had a front page picture
of Rick lens with girls as big titties
on either side of it while Rick was like
kind of a religious nut and his wife was
a real religious nut and so she really
literally called them pulled them out of
there by his ear you know you're you're
quitting it so we needed a straight man
and so this Russian publisher of a
hippie magazine he's I know just a guy
he's this guy he's really funny his name
is Richard Marin and so he's come on
meet him so I went out and met Cheech
for the first time and he was a little
look like Johnny Mathis clone you know
the short hair you look like a little
money you know and so I met him and I
said they told him what we were doing he
said okay I'll come down and check it
out
so he came down and the reason I hired
him it was when he walked in because we
had the improv things set up we had
doors and curtains and so we're
backstage we could see the audience and
I looked out and he walked in with one
of the most beautiful women I've ever
seen in my life you know [ __ ] long
pullings Minko
tall beautiful brunette just gorgeous
and teach walk Daniel like he owned the
place I said this guy's got something
going so you saw it he saw the show you
liked the show and so we hired him and
he was he was the understudy for a
couple of months and then when my
brother fired us because we weren't
making any money we had turned the crowd
from a strip joint
you know guys throw money and you know
add anything to what he called actors or
co2 co2 people are coming and they would
order a wine and counter change you
excuse me you still owe me a dollar you
know that kind of thing
so we were losing money and so my
brother said we had we have to go back
to the strip format you know so you guys
are out of here and so teaching and so
everybody out the girls went right back
stripping no problem Dave went right
back on the door and teach now were the
only ones that was what are we gonna do
so we put a band together yeah because
I'm a musician he's a singer but we
never our first gig we never played one
note we just went out did comedy all the
bits that we had done an on stage and
that was the beginning of Cheech and
Chong I'm what year was that that was
1969 1969 now what made you at that time
because now if you look back its
visionary yeah
what made you put the first album
together Oh easy teach and I came down
for the struggle the first club we'd
worked was red foxes club down Asia yeah
where was red foxes close on La Cienega
it was the only only comedy club in town
1970 that was 1969 still said or 70 no
the subdued a it was 70 and yeah red
wasn't in town he was out working and
Norma Mailer she was the manager so she
she she had us come down there she
couldn't pronounce her name Cheech and
Chong she called us geek and gank and
the geek and gank what so we we did a
bit and then Lenny Bruce's entourage
Lenny had died a couple of years earlier
and so his entourage including Sally
Marr they would come to the other clubs
or the Redd Foxx club looking for the
other Lenny and they said they saw
Cheech and Chong and so Tony Bishara
Lenny's brother father-in-law his young
guy Chicano also ex jailbird he he
spotted us come up to me right away and
he goes you you guys are the closest
thing to Lin
since since Lenny died and and he became
not a not a so much a manager although I
hired him every chance I got I hired him
try to get him to be a roadie for us
that didn't work out if we can use the
junkie you know so I tried I tried then
just before he died I hired him as a
writer for nice dreams but the reason we
got the record was we'd better not we
were almost the regulars at the
troubadour for the hootenanny night and
we started going down there you had to
go there you had a lineup at 9:00 in the
morning get there at 9:00 and Lee's
around nine o'clock your earlier if you
had to so you could be first in line and
then we wait until six o'clock to the to
the box office open and then we would
sign up and then we'd be the six but on
on stage we had then that the nice time
and so we did that for a few almost a
year and then Lou Adler heard about us
came down sauce and invited us to meet
in his office we went in there and
because I had that Lenny Bruce you know
background listening to records
especially up in Canada you know I knew
how to do comedy record so so when Lou
said what he wanted what do you want
like let's do a comedy record and he
said okay what do you need he said give
us a couple of grand you were in each
row to check we paid the rent we were
off to the races
you know Chung I um not woke as they say
you have to be welcome to society but
this still things that I remember from
my youth that still overtake Who I am
today
I've shot two comedy specials and I've
hated them both I have a great time
doing out one of my best pieces of work
I think isn't how I did oh man I'm gonna
hear and but the funny thing is I came
from an album me Society yeah
okay yeah delirious came later when I
was growing up you couldn't go on
youtube and watch Lenny [ __ ] Bruce no
so I didn't get into any proof to
basically YouTube came on when I had to
comedy somebody gave me a VHS of Lenny
yeah but even when it comes to the
podcast the main reason why I wanted to
start a podcast was to make America
listen again yeah something we have
forgotten I learned to listen because of
loss Pacino's big bamboo was it
something I said
and Bicentennial [ __ ] those four albums
taught me how to listen but they also
set the groundwork for me to what I
wanted my copy to sound like I don't
want it perfect yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
gritty yeah I like grit okay well what
makes you laugh what makes me laugh your
albums are brilliant and they'll never
ever happen again in the comedy realm
because they're too overproduced no in
today's world we over produce nothing
what's the producers there they're the
kings they're the ones that do it they
the ones that do it in my world me in a
perfect Joey Diaz world the best special
I've ever seen in my life is Richard
Pryor from that [ __ ] coffee shop with
the menu behind them yeah okay because I
felt like I was there yeah you see a
special now and there's theatres and
there's curtains and they show us
walking and smoking a joint that never
happened no that never happened
I like grit I like that seventies grit
yeah I miss it I miss today you tape
something you know music do you any live
albums anymore no do they even make
[ __ ] live albums and him no no they
have lost an art we took away an art
from us they don't even use musicians
anymore yeah no now they want to do you
know they sample everything they sample
every day and no now they're doing the
hologram tour she's coming on the show
pretty soon for Ronnie James deal but
people that understand out solution
have you seen the hologram thing I saw
pictures yeah I've seen pride he tried
to get us involved in it but and you
know it's like a magic show it's like
yeah they're not there that's not to
park it might be this music it might
look like you but that's it's not too
bad you know and so what the [ __ ] you
know or you think god they said they can
bring Elvis back or they gonna bring all
that no you can bring a picture of a
picture hanging but we see that on TV
every day you know there's nothing and
watch you any commercial you're gonna
see that [ __ ] you know so there's
nothing to entice you to go in your
pocket and pay some money to go see a
hologram of somebody else's then you
know it's not there you know there's
something disabled the human flesh it's
real you know but it's which it's very
weird that if you see look at my left
eye I still have over a while you have
comedy albums I love that and some
nights have nothing to do with the house
the baby goes to sleep at 8:30 and I'll
come here I'll put it down the first
often in an alumn unless it has a little
bump to it yeah so even if you find just
shake bamboo today like if you go to a
homey bar and somebody sold isn't garage
sale or something or we sign them all
the time sign them all the time and I
tell you something the true
professionals never touch that paper no
they have never touched that rolling I
know it wasn't meant to be rolled it's a
roll I don't think has no glue so people
was still putting weeding there you know
how many parties I went there what
people were like we roll the joint with
the paper up in their face or they would
take a little corner of the paper right
yeah I mean why destroy a piece of art
or a [ __ ] paper you can get a
cigarette paper anywhere but by but till
today
yeah when I go to New York City when I'm
here in town I buy papers the white ones
yep one of the white ones that come
white orange and the other one zigzag
zigzag zigzag too as soon as I step off
the [ __ ] plan I'd buy bamboo and easy
why I'm still a big bamboo guy I was
smoking big bamboo but we've came with
seeds yeah you would light up never
explode yeah I had a deal I used to hit
the seeds with with hammers crush your
crush a month they get weight and you
can't finish smoking or they would
explode it'll pop every shirt you had
had a burn mark in it because people the
seeds would blow all the public popcorn
you don't know how many times I will sit
in this chair talk to people about the
value of albums in this country and I
think that you guys with the big bamboo
really opened up a lot of people's minds
with that roman when did you get that
idea actually
and big bamboo went along with you know
for sure are they loved it they've been
sending me all sorts of [ __ ] they're
trying to even give me going again with
the big man but a Lou Adler was the
marketing genius genius and so what he
did he found the right artist now the
only problem he had a heart like a lot
of producers he had hard time paying and
paying them the artists and so what
happened the guy that that to design big
bamboo he got paid for that but then
they went on another photo shoot and
they try to do a another one and they
got the tens of people they had Faye
Dunaway and Warren Beatty everybody else
at this photo shoot and but it never
never made the cut and sewn together so
Lou never paid the guys and so the guys
just contacted me recently the artist
and said we got all this material would
you like it and we're shooting we're
doing a documentary I said uh yeah thank
you
and so he brought all this treasure
trove of teaching high and a photo shoot
and stuff material no one's ever seen
before but there was that it was the
artist
Craig Braun was the guy that did the
bamboo the bamboo album he did the
Rolling Stone - he did the tongue the
rolling stone really yeah now let me ask
you a question because this wasn't 2009
Kien when you release the album with a
rolling paper it it was 1972 yeah okay
Vietnam was either ending no one knows
it was still on no I think victim went
to 73 Vietnam was still around you know
you couldn't go to your nearest
dispensary you couldn't go to the corner
and why the joint and talk to your
friend on the corner cuz a cop
helicopter would be there was there any
backlash oh yeah at the time I mean what
was it was uh when when it suited their
purposes you know like remember and when
what's that singer and that got caught
showing his dick on stage Louis you
can't no no way back
the singer Morrison Jim Morrison Jim
Morrison's because they got Miami in
Miami in mind okay so when he did that
then the hall all those venues put a
clause in their contract that if you
broke any kind of piece like that you
you would have to paid the hall five
thousand dollars and so Chetan I played
the same hall in Tampa Florida they
arrested US for obscenity and but they
didn't charge us it was just a scam so
the hall owner could make an extra five
grand so teach me I got taken to jail
and but that was funny we got a funny
but what was obscenity what was it was
us acting like wow I don't know what it
was I think we were acting like dogs we
get on our hands and knees and and sniff
each others butts and I think what
happened they had the cops are lining
around the stage facing the audience you
know and sit there you're gonna stop
Trump some kind of riot or something and
so Cheech when he was a dog he walked
over on his hands and knees and he
picked up one of the cops hats off his
head and act like he was peeing on the
cop you know yeah I think that might
have contributed somewhat to us being
arrested
but we got arrested they put us in jail
man
Nazi I've been in incarcerated a few
times you know when I was young
Cheech his father was a cop right and
Cheech
I mean he breaks into a sweat just
thinking about jail and so he he he was
mad at first when we went to jail we
didn't think we're gonna be there long
you know again we just got upstaged you
got a standing ovation everything I was
mixing you know we're sitting in a
holding cell with a bunch of other
people and and there's one Chicano guy
in jail it was to teach in Spanish you
know anybody in jail for him and teach
drugs you know he didn't want to say an
obscenity so he's at drugs there's other
day the latino guy goes oh tell him up
like I send it to you and tell him a
black guy could give it to him and that
was her thing and then she's going in
jail he was teasing the the the guard
its ojl Tandi jail Tandy could we have
some pink toilet tissue in here please
and you don't [ __ ] around with guards
they hear everything they act like they
don't hear anything but they hear
everything they know exactly who said it
and so we were there so long that we
ended up sitting down because before
that we're standing up waiting to get
released and then I wear it longer and
then the the that same guard the Cheech
bug because of the cheese hey you come
with me I heard was teachers leoben's my
dad's a cop you know my dad's a LAPD he
tried to convince the guy that he was he
was on their side but we got out it was
a big publicity thing we got a picture
of our mug shots and you've sold more
tickets
yeah no more popular just made it yeah
he's got an international press on that
one yeah that same as me going to jail
same thing you know I turned into an
icon you know so it didn't bother didn't
bother my fans at all you know you know
so here I am a young kid I'm
to the album's I'm into prior I'm into
smoking marijuana
the whole thing and then boom now I hate
doing movies yeah and you know I didn't
have time to watch the movies before you
came on I thought it would be cheesy
today all of a sudden start hitting you
know questions I remember two things
from a movie the band and Cheech came
out with the two to bond I forget the
song he was singing I want to be in the
matter what mama Tucker don't meet down
at that band yeah you know I mean come
on when you're 12 or 13 and you take all
a red microdot acid and take the number
one bus to Jersey City by the time you
get to Jersey City you're on fire and
you'd walk into this you know that this
is just sitting here watching you I'm
listening to you but I didn't really
understand the power that is charm
yeah till today this is 60 years of real
this is a okey-doke [ __ ] no this is from
Michael Jackson to Motown to movie's
director instert you know I mean the
movies and your albums trapped in fact
that yeah like they made it like number
10 oh yeah I mean this is just
phenomenal did you think this was the
way when you were when you were putting
down the vocals a big bamboo
did you see 2019
no yeah what were you thinking at the
time you're eating
oh just had a wife happy we're right in
the middle of creating when we first the
first bit we did was an accident
you know after we got our money from Lou
you know a thousand a couple of thousand
dollars and I said oh and we need a
little tape recorder I thought that
would be a nice little added thing and
so he got his secretary got us a little
tape recorder and so Cheech and I went
in the back mixdown room in am studios
and we were practicing we're rehearsing
and so Cheech was so used to working
live that he went outside you put on us
and everything else he's gonna be a dope
dealer and and he goes outside and the
door locks from the inside and it was
really hot out there that was like in
a.m. in the middle of summer the sun's
beating down on him so he knocked on the
door he goes and I'm supposed to let him
in I guess so I was trying to record the
the the side the little tape recorder
and so when he knocked I looked up at
the door and I didn't see if the needle
was moving or not and so I said who is
it
and cheech's it's me man and I looked
down and I seen the needle movement so
it's recording and so I'm looking at it
staring at it and was set pause and then
he knocked again so I said oh I thought
I'll start the bit over again so I said
who is it
and I heard it in his voice little
pissed off it's it's me man open up come
on I think the cops on me so now I got
him outside the door's locked he can't
get in I'm waiting for him to knock
again because he's so so disciplined
once we get into a bed he can't get out
of it and so he knocks again this time a
little harder and I go who is it it's me
man Dave Dave no let me in it's hot out
here I said Dave yeah yeah Dave
Dave's not here so I the door
and he wanted to punch me he was
betrayed he was sweating I said wait
wait wait listen listen and I played it
back and that was the beginning of a
record career not only the beginning of
our a recording career but was beginning
of our style of how we would do it we
didn't need anybody we didn't need a lot
of engineers we just needed one guy to
work the tape recorder
in a little room and that's all we had
and then we put all the sound effects
everything else in there
the first Dave's not here was recorded
on the big stage was Lou Adler who
either did the whole thing he did Blind
Melon chitlin and all that you know
because after we did Dave's not here
they said okay what else you got
and sheets that looked at each other we
hadn't even thought about writing
another bed and so we just did our live
show which was Blind Melon chillin and
it was an Blind Melon chitlin was a bit
that I got from the committee the
committee who used to do a bit on a
blind blues singer and so I know I was
influenced by it let's say it that way
put it that way in and so we made up the
record the Blind Melon children as in
the in the studio and then we realized
that we didn't need all the engineers
and the producers and everything else
and so Cheech and I just just a producer
and I mean the engineer and Cheech and I
norm Kenny and Cheech and Chong and
worked every day just going there which
is very really relaxed like we're doing
now exactly this is very brilliant I
mean these stories uh like I said now
I'm talking to you I'm getting to see
how much you influence what you guys did
oh yeah stuck with me forever like I
before I did this podcast the person was
editing it and I didn't really enjoy it
and it was basically because of what you
guys did with your house yeah they
sounded so raw yeah and that's what I've
always liked I've always liked I'm gonna
I'm never gonna shoot a special yet I
mean I really don't want to shoot a
special yeah she don't want to tape [ __ ]
I want to put it on vinyl next time yeah
I want to put my [ __ ] on vinyl and I
want people to have the same experience
that you gave me yeah
that experience has been taken away we
had the guy from the Guns and Roses a
few weeks ago definitely absolutely keg
and Duff only were talking about that
that would have meant for children to
have a paper route delivered [ __ ]
lose pay
so we get paid on Saturday and Saturday
me Tony Lee and Chung would walk down
sunset over your 12 to your favorite
record store and you were gonna get Led
Zeppelin to Chung don't [ __ ] around hit
Richard Pryor
because Chang was always the one I would
switch his [ __ ] mind prior now my
dad's alive but that you know you got
these albums you took them home you know
explain to them how you open the out you
read the credits and while you were
reading the credits are you clean your
weed yeah on the album cover and then
you took your weed that's why sometimes
you go buy a second-hand out and if it
opens up there's two seeds in there and
it does something to you gets a little
crippled you guys took it one above yeah
you guys took to me once you guys put
the rolling paper in that album that
created album covers like some girls and
stones which you could rotate and Led
Zeppelin three I think you could also
rotate it gave people more freedom what
to do with their albums I don't know if
you ever thought about it not no
direction this [ __ ] was genius to me
that like I said till today I still
believe in it and I believe the record
companies the money is down because you
don't entertain people like that anymore
if I buy something from from Chung now I
open it up and it's just a disc you know
there's no pictures of the tour nothing
there's no pictures of you in the
recording studio no you and your
bathroom with your pants off because
your mom that's what we want to see a
poster yeah a poster of you and and and
she'll be with the dog yeah and he's got
a hemp pad on yeah who gives a [ __ ] yeah
that those little things yeah made that
795 come out of your pocket a lot easier
yeah you know what even if the album is
a five look at the [ __ ] poster how
cool is there and they may be a [ __ ]
rolling papers and a lot of times you
had a you couldn't play it right away
you had a waiting to you and their mind
was right
oh yeah that's no point to join yeah and
then you had to be very special yeah
you had to have your head in the right
spot see you I'm when I was coming up
you know poor ass musician you know I
was married before Shelby in fact Shelby
was a neighbor and my first wife Maxine
she was the one that that supported me
you know she was the one I had a [ __ ]
job and she put that job you know and so
I quit and I just start playing music
and then next thing you know the guy
gives us a club and we we got some money
coming in but being poor and just
concentrating on what you love to do man
that really helped and I could never
have done it without the help of ladies
you know my way me neither my beer my
wife was gone for five days I didn't
know what the [ __ ] underwear I know
how kind of [ __ ] stove on in my house
and I do the microwave and stuff I don't
know the time the [ __ ] no one any one
house I got to tell you something I know
your time is limited I don't I wanted
you to say that you influenced me in so
many ways and you've you're a true
[ __ ] hero of mine because you
influenced America on the knowledge of
marijuana you know and you came along
Ozzy Osbourne wrote [ __ ] sweet leaf
you know listen to lyrics to sleep
weightless sweet leaf someday you know
the world will love you I should I'll
get I was in Boulder we're talking about
Boulder he was that last week and in
this I was a getter I got invited by
this top astrologist she's in Boulder
Debra's Silberman she said oh you got to
meet this girl some but the hippie in
this hippie girl I'm going back in time
this there was all sentinels in the 60s
again and and then her girlfriend she's
turned lesbian and she her girlfriend is
this singer singer that wrote all these
great weed songs and it's like a rap
sounds like
Taylor Swift sounds like her doing a
song about weed it's so cool and she
gave me a couple of CDs I'll get them
over to you
you'll love them I mean you play them on
your show yeah oh man you'll love them
this has been very eye-opening for me
because I didn't see all the great
things you did to you in front of me I
mean you're the real deal Motown family
do all movies Miami Vice she went to
jail and while you're out swinging dick
like it doesn't end and I also helped
Wolf of Wall Street
you know the more Wall Street right I
helped him and I shared the cubicle and
so I would I was writing my book you
know my memoirs and he would be playing
tennis and Jordan Belfort and he come in
said what are you doing there I'm
writing writing a book he goes I'm gonna
write a book so he started writing and
then he handed me a page and it was like
a copy of Thomas Wolfe bonfire of the
vanities and all the word-for-word
almost you know I said you have a
written [ __ ] man because he's a genius
you know he got all upset he's well what
do you think I should write I said write
those stories you've been telling me
every night you know and I give him a
little hand Isis the key is the most of
you don't just get high you get higher
than anybody's ever gotten high in
cinema you know and so he took me to
heart next thing you know he gets out of
jail I get out of jail and he comes over
to my house because we're both on
probation we couldn't talk to each other
face to face so he's in his car he peeps
his horn he goes hey I sold my book it's
gonna be a movie it's gonna score says
he's gonna direct it
oh [ __ ] just like that and so he's been
going around giving lectures in that now
and telling everybody that I helped him
write a writer's book so yeah my I I'm
on a very special path and I'm meeting
at all sorts of people you know I
watched John Rogan and you said that
when you very interesting
when you went jail unit a little
religious yeah experience like a
religious retreat yeah and I really
identify with you at that yeah because I
looked at it as I looked at it as uh as
a Buddhist yeah I didn't looking as a
Catholic you know I was going in there
to solve my sins paid for them and I had
a second chance at life to start over
this is the ultimate payment for your
sins this covers all of them yeah you
didn't get arrested for the bottom no
you didn't go to jail for the bottom
that was just a story that the universe
made up yeah for you to pay you know
knowing that I was in there to cleanse
your acquaintance with myself again yeah
and that's what it did for me too I
didn't have peace of mind for eight
years I won in that and I met pick Joey
Diaz you meet the wants and you also
realized what you don't want everybody
well you don't need where you don't need
your life yeah I want to thank you for
the great gifts you sent me from pure
hemp yeah what's it called Chung's bland
choice Tong's choice that half the joint
took me to [ __ ] and I want to tell you
you always welcomed me if you want to
[ __ ] whatever you want to do okay
you have a life long I'm your new nephew
because I'm not even a fan I'm beyond
the fan I love how was more starstruck
today with your conversations and your
beauty in your journey
this [ __ ] journey has been if God
forbid if God takes you tomorrow on the
way up you know I know
why did a beautiful journey I introduced
people and two of the greatest gifts
that you would give somebody laughter
and they gift the reefer thank you the
gift the reefer when you turn somebody
out the reefer and they really need in
their soul and it covers that spread for
them that they don't need alcohol don't
need anything I was just reefer
you feel good I don't know how anybody
else feels I feel good I don't feel good
when I dosed me with 6,000 milligrams of
THC he sleeps here for two days that
doesn't make me feel
you and I have a great sense of humor
yeah I bet you're great at dosing people
to like take a hit of this and won't do
that until you engage you oh yeah many
times how many times did you talk so he
was my change
why don't have to with him he does it on
himself yeah yeah yeah he had a date
with Joni Mitchell one time she was
playing a concert in in Paris and we
were shooting a movie in Paris and he
had in him and Joni and you know kind of
secretly dated on the side so she was a
she was gonna appear in in Paris and so
he had a piece of hash and he did no way
to smoke it so he's not [ __ ] he so
hated the whole chunk of hash
he got so stoned he forgot to eat
everybody got their food and I looked
over and he was that stoned I've been
there oh and he still does it to this
day and he tries not to that's our love
about of you know because yeah I can't
do that I can't do that and then he
picked up a syringe one time and he
thought oh I'll just do a little bit
he's almost there was like Rick Simpson
oil this [ __ ] will put you away for it
for for a month
what's Rick Simpson all stuff that cures
cancer yeah yeah it's so strong
it's so strong and literally the cancer
cells in your [ __ ] I'm out of here
dude why'd you have a syringe from well
that's oh no you okay oh it's like Black
Widow his wife said he was projectile
vomiting and that was when he was is
really goes to the Wailing Wall does the
same thing he thought it was a breath
mint at the Wailing Wall
yeah he puts a whole dose of something
and is that they're whaling well and but
these are barfing in the in the cab so I
think
that they turn the Willing well into the
puking wall
oh man and Cheech is great in there you
gotta have teacher and your back on your
back on the road oh yeah yeah yeah and
full tour starting in September yeah how
did these people get to your day we want
that lively night gunshot OH there's no
chong kham or the feds won't let you in
another webpage most part of your
brother's Cheech and Chong calm I'll get
a chance choice okay okay so there's a
shitload of them so like the fire the
dates on Live Nation and I'm teaching
Chung dr. joy I gotta go take a piss
do you think okay I love you to death I
love you guys Chung I want to thank you
again you're a gentleman and a true
[ __ ] no oh you [ __ ] I'm just gonna
keep talking I love you guys thank you
very much for listening to the Church of
what's happening I wanna thank John
again I want to thank Tony for bringing
him up here I want to thank you for
bringing up the weed for us and the pure
hemp and real quick while I have you
here that's it I'll be in Columbus next
Friday and Saturday night Columbus
funnybone 7 and 9 I don't know what the
[ __ ] the time is make sure you're there
that's what I'm asking here right then
on the fifth of July I'm at the rec room
in Orange County but don't worry about
that let's worry about potato salad all
that [ __ ] for right now all you got to
worry about is [ __ ] the funny bone
Columbus all right real quick I want to
give a word to our sponsors all right I
want to thank my man Tommy Chong that
was a [ __ ] great
I spent some great time with him every
time I looked at the guy I felt like
crying because he meant that much to me
in my life I want to thank the
[ __ ] was gonna be it skank
fastest weekend walk through New York
from the Eastside comedy club so [ __ ]
go on his Twitter he'll keep twitting
your ways gonna be if you want to meet
him and I want to thank you guys for
being [ __ ] the church family if always
having our back I also want to take time
out to thank our sponsors because they
what keeps her afloat number one CBD
Lyon listen your days of walking around
like a [ __ ] Zombo looking for CBD or a
dumbwit okay you're walking around you
believe
what this guy tells you what that guy
tells you [ __ ] them all you're paying
for [ __ ] oh gods you're getting
garbage listen when you're looking for a
reliable CBD company [ __ ] it I got it
for you you ready grab a pen
CBD lion calm lucky for you
[ __ ]
I found CBD Lyon they make CBD products
from start to finish
that's what CBD luck the lion does they
have you covered
they it comes in a vape it comes in
cartridges it comes in the tension it
comes in the chatter and don't even let
me get me start on the [ __ ] gummies
the strawberry or the raspberry gummies
will put you over the [ __ ] top the
orange ones ain't that bad either I love
their [ __ ] gummies I eat four of them
before I go to Bennett man I don't wake
up in the middle night to pee and I'm 56
I gotta pee every [ __ ] 15 minutes so
you do the math CBD line is the real
[ __ ] deal their products are clean
you understand me
clean Bobby not like the fakes out there
at all these [ __ ] liquor stores when
my bet my brother I went to the liquor
store and they go what the [ __ ]
he sells vodka what the [ __ ] does he
know about CBD our Uncle Joe is here I
live right in the heart of this [ __ ]
jungle here of marijuana I'm telling you
CBD line is the way to go right go to
CBD line.com right now and check out
their third-party results right now
yourself they got them right up on the
website your [ __ ] hands gonna [ __ ]
fly out of yet that's how good CBD Lyon
is so do me a favor go to CBD line that
net.com right now look at the fine line
and stuff whether you want to go with
the shanna whether you want to go to
cartridges as a matter of fact they're
releasing a new 4/20 cartridge 420
milligram cartridge today today so go to
CBD line.com right now present Church CH
you are CH and get 20% off your
[ __ ] order that's how Joey does
it here and number two it's summertime I
bring you two she do I not do I not try
to take care listen you can wash your
balls til [ __ ] Saint Gerardo's day the
problem is you got that [ __ ] Bush
down there growing out of your dicks out
of your [ __ ] out of your ball sack
out of your [ __ ] belly button so you
got four contributing factors of stink
going towards one [ __ ] area which is
your nutsack then you sit there and
you're like I can't find nobody on
tinder I can't find nobody on tender
they come over they don't want to suck
my dick baby because you got a Bush of
death down there but that comes to an
end right now because you got manscaped
Joey what the [ __ ] is manscape manscape
they got precision tools for the Family
Jewels okay manscape has redesigned the
electric razor their invention what
brought them to the [ __ ] dance is
called a lawnmower a handheld razor with
skin safe technology Joey what's that
what's that you're not gonna cut your
[ __ ] dick off that's what that is
it won't Nick or snag your [ __ ]
nutsack cuz you gotta go easy guys you
gotta go easy and you just can't trust
people you can't ask your mother to trim
you know there's and you can't ask your
grandmother trim you and that is so you
gotta meet some [ __ ] chick who you
trust who you've never done nothing bad
to to trim you [ __ ] nut sack
have you ever done it yeah your [ __ ]
wife you fired on oh yeah
you pull the blankets overhead she's
bound to want to cut one of your [ __ ]
nut sacks off I mean I would right or
wrong no more why because you got to
manscape this bad boy will leave you
clean smooth anxiety-free plus it's
rechargeable and easier to hold you get
into all the nooks and crannies you fat
little [ __ ] [ __ ] you got a pic
your stomach up to shave that thing how
do I know cuz I'm a fat [ __ ] myself you
got to pick your leg up and put behind
your head and trim that [ __ ] bush of
death and it also has a little [ __ ]
knob that you could trim the outstanding
hairs out of your [ __ ] you know I'm
saying you can't go in there because god
forbid but manscape will get your bean
bag looking as smooth as a [ __ ] egg
all right I'm gonna let you know a
little secret if you trim the hedges the
pole of death looks a lot [ __ ] small
bigger alright so what are you waiting
for trim up that [ __ ] egg roll of
love you want to go out there and give
some mustard to these girls in the mouth
it starts with manscape god you get
everything you need to make your ball
shine like [ __ ] lee's head you keep
your dick looking good and if this is
the first time you consider man's game
but they got a deal for you grab a pen
the perfect package comes with a
lawnmower and a safety razor plus plus
the crop preserve or especially
formulated deodorant so your nuts don't
stink plus the Reviver let's say you
play volleyball and you had a little
Wang - you're not seeing your dick you
go behind a [ __ ] phone booth or a car
and you wipe out your dick with nobody
watching and you go out to the bar and
give some [ __ ] stop making juice to
these [ __ ] freaks at that anyway the
church family right now today the church
gets 20% off your first daughter when
you use promo code Church BAM at
manscape babcom again
that's manscape calm and if you are the
perfect package
they'll also throw in a free travel bag
when you use promo code Church that's
manscape calm use promo code church for
20% off your first daughter remember you
gotta keep the nutsack clean and it
starts with manscape time I want to
thank manscape
I want to thank CB beeline calm I want
to thank all you [ __ ] for being
family remember I'll see you savages of
death next weekend at the Columbus
funnybone get you tickets thing cuz I
gotta go fast all the pond
it's [ __ ] remember they gotta get
tickets alright I love your
[ __ ] have a great weekend stay
black and we'll be back Monday morning
tip Tuesday morning tip top Magoo ready
for you kick this [ __ ] mule Lee once
and for all